So you've heard me say this is not a rehearsal.
This is this is the emergency.
The Postal Service says tens of millions of
ballots, mail in ballots, absentee ballots
are at risk of not being counted.
The United States Postal Service is warning
that 46 states and Washington, D.C. in July,
they warned tens of millions of voters might
not have their votes counted because of the
slow mail processing of absentee ballot applications
and eventual ballots that in April.
Washington Post has the story.
That was the earliest sign from the post office
that if they do kneecap them in terms of funding,
which the Trump administration is trying to
do, it could affect ballot delivery.
Now, I really need people to understand this
because Donald Trump and Trump is saying something
very different.
The problem here is not the volume of ballots.
OK, please look at the numbers.
Every holiday season, you know, November,
December into New Year, the post office regularly
handles about one point three billion greeting
cards around the country.
OK, even if every voter voted by mail, we're
looking at somewhere between 120 and 130 million
people voting.
That's only 10 percent of the normal volume
of greeting cards.
OK, if we just let the post office do its
thing, it would have no problem handling mail
in ballots, even if every ballot was by mail
instead of in-person.
But that's not going to be the case.
Only some people are planning to vote absentee
or vote by mail.
The problem is, if you cut hours, if you limit
overtime, if you closed down post offices,
if you shut down mailboxes, if you quote,
reorganize the post office the way Lewis Dejoy
wants to do, you will then cause a problem
for the post office being able to deliver
and do everything that they have to do.
The warning from the post office applies to
186 million potential voters.
Now, not all of those voters are expected
to vote by mail.
So that's why in practice, it will probably
affect tens of millions rather than, you know,
186 million, which is the number of people
that could vote in some of these states.
It's in blue states.
It's in red states.
It's in battleground states like Pennsylvania,
Wisconsin, Michigan.
So there's a few suggestions here that are
just commonsense.
I'm going to have a story tomorrow, by the
way, my mail.
This is today.
Well, I'll mention it.
This is crazy.
My absentee ballot application took 14 days
to go three miles.
OK.
I'm going to talk about that tomorrow.
But as far as suggestions, request your ballots
as early as you can, return your ballot as
early as you can.
It likely will be too late for some people
in some states like it seems that we've reached
a post office kneecapping escape velocity
for lack of a better term.
We are unfortunately looking at a situation
where if you want higher confidence that your
vote will be counted.
You might have to vote in person.
Now, I want to be careful here.
I'm not suggesting anybody do anything unsafe,
but I'm talking about wearing a mask and all
of that stuff.
What I am saying is we're hearing from the
post office itself that they are being sabotaged
or sabotaged.
Edged as as William Shatner says, and this
administration is trying to find a way for
your vote not to count.
Now there is some intermediate good news and
this made some some waves over the weekend.
And I do want to amplify it in a lot of places.
If you get your ballot in the mail, you don't
have to send it in through the mail.
You can drop it off.
And different municipalities have different
places.
Town hall, city hall, different municipal
offices.
Figure out the specifics in your community.
In other places, if it's 10 days before the
election and you don't have your ballot, for
example, you might have to vote in person
to make sure your vote is going to be counted.
And that's horrifying.
I don't want to pretend that that's not a
possibility.
But because it is, Trump is against funding
the post office.
His postmaster general has reassigned 23 postal
executives and is sort of circling the wagons
and consolidating power.
They are talking about the post office like
it's a business when really it's a public
service.
You don't say we can't do it.
You say, well, okay, what do we have to do
to make sure that they can do it?
That's what a normal president would do.
This president says, let's make sure that
they can't do it.
So really, keep in mind that this local drop
off might be a good idea.
I checked in Boston.
How does it work in Boston?
In Boston?
The election Web site says if you want to
return your ballot in person, you can do that
anytime city hall is open, but you've got
to go to city hall now.
Doesn't seem ideal that anybody all of Boston
needs to go to city hall to return their ballots
in person.
But it is something in New York City.
I found that, quote, All borough offices are
equipped with ballot marking devices available
for voters up until Election Day.
Look it up in your community.
Remember, they want to take everything away
from government.
So making the post office fail at something
as natural as just delivering ballots is part
of them building up the case that we should
be replacing the post office with private
industry anyway.
And they have the added benefit this time
around that they might be able to win an election
if they're able to do it.
Very scary.
I, I want to say this is being taken as seriously
as it should.
I don't know if it is.
I'm doing everything I can to sound the alarm.
No, the options, understand the timelines.
Figure out where you can drop off your absentee
ballot in person if you're able if you have
transportation and you're able to do it.
Very, very important stuff because this could
get really ugly really quickly.